ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen die
Ex sowie Republik als aserbaidschan hat
einen Militäreinsatz im Südkaukasus in
der umstrittenen Region Bergkarabach
gestartet laut dem
Verteidigungsministerium in Baku richte
sich der Einsatz gegen armenische
militärstellungen in der Region ihr seht
jetzt hier gleich aktuelle Bilder die
Rede ist von einem
Anti-Terror-Einsatz Stellungen an der
Front und im Hinterland Einrichtungen
und geschützpositionen würden mit
Präzisionswaffen außer Gefecht gesetzt
Ziel sei so wörtlich die
Wiederherstellung der verfassungsmäßigen
Ordnung
ja den Konflikt zwischen Bergkarabach
und den Konflikt um der Karbach so ist
richtig zwischen Aserbaidschan und
Armenien die gibt es seit Jahrzehnten
schon zwei blutige Kriege gab es
zwischen den beiden Ländern zuletzt vor
drei Jahren wir wollen uns jetzt noch
einmal anschauen wo dieser Konflikt
eigentlich spielt wo er sich zuträgt die
Region ist ungefähr so groß wie das
Saarland und gehört völkerrechtlich zu
Aserbaidschan der Karabach ist aber vor
allem unter armenischer Kontrolle der
Großteil der 150.000 Einwohner innen
sind Armenia der einzige Weg in die
Region ein kleiner Korridor wird von
Aserbaidschan seit Monaten blockiert
beobachter fürchten einen Genozid durch
die schlechte Versorgung mit
Medikamenten und Lebensmitteln Russland
galt lange als Schutzmacht Armeniens
Putin hielt sich in der
Auseinandersetzung aber zuletzt zurück
so wir wollen heute darüber sprechen wie
die Lage in der Region ist warum kommt
es jetzt zu einer Eskalation und könnte
daraus noch ein größerer Flächenbrand
für die ganze Region entstehen könnten
zum Beispiel die Türkei und der Iran
damit reingezogen werden und welche
Rolle spielt Russland in dem Konflikt
und auch Putin und nutzte ihm vielleicht
sogar darüber spreche ich mit meinem
Kollegen Armin Körper in Moskau meine
Kollegin Nina Niebergall die Armenien
begeistert die ist gleich bei mir hier
im Studio und ich spreche mit Marcel
Röthig von der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung
im süd-kaukasus der uns hilft den
Konflikt und die Verbindung in die
Weltpolitik besser zu verstehen und wie
immer gilt für euch Fragen und Gedanken
zum Thema gerne hier direkt im Chat
kommentieren oder er schickt sie uns per
Mail an die Mail Adresse die ihr
eingeblendet seht die Leute ZDF heute -
live at zdf.de
so und jetzt schalten wir zu meinem
Kollegen Armin Körper der für uns in
maska wartet hallo Armin grüß Dich
guten Abend erstmal
Armin welche aktuellen Informationen
hast du zu der aktuellen Eskalation für
uns
also die russische Nachrichtenagentur
Interfax meldet ist von meldet es gäbe
25 Tote in Bergkarabach und wir sehen
heute abend Bilder aus der armenischen
Hauptstadt jerevan wo Demonstranten vor
dem Regierungssitz von Premierminister
Nicole paschinian auf marschiert sind
sie drohen den Regierungssitz zu stürmen
sie ist kandieren azach azach das ist
das armenische Wort für Bergkarabach und
die Polizei geht ziemlich hart gegen die
Demonstranten vor
Armin es gab zuletzt Jahr 2020 ein Krieg
in der Region mit mehr als 6000 Toten
danach war eigentlich ein
Waffenstillstand vereinbart worden
vermittelt durch Russland warum jetzt
diese Eskalation
also es gehört zur Rhetorik in diesem
Konflikt der einer der ältesten der Welt
ist dass die beiden Konfliktparteien
sich immer gegenseitig vorwerfen
Waffenstillstände gebrochen zu haben so
ist das auch heute wenn man sich aber
jetzt die Ereignisse der letzten Monate
mal genauer anguckt dann sieht man das
eigentlich viel auf eine solche
Eskalation hingedeutet hat als
Aserbaidschan Berg Karabach wir haben es
gerade schon gehört abgeriegelt hat und
eigentlich eine humanitäre Katastrophe
damit provoziert hat da haben die
russischen Friedenstruppen die seit drei
Jahren dort stationiert sind einfach
tatenlos zugeschaut man muss wissen die
Türkei unterstützt als Aserbaidschan und
Russland ist vertraglich seit 1995 die
Schutz Macht von Armenien das alles hat
gezeigt dass Russland sich von Armenien
abwendet vielleicht in dem Ukraine
Konflikt mehr Interesse an Beziehungen
zu Aserbaidschan und auch zur Türkei hat
das hat man natürlich in Armenien zu
Erkenntnis genommen hat daraufhin
Hilfslieferungen in die Ukraine
geschickt hat Militärmanöver mit den USA
durchgeführt das wiederum fand man
hinter mir im Kreml überhaupt nicht
witzig also das ganze hat sich auf eine
eskaliation
hinzugespielt last but not least vor
drei Wochen haben sich Putin und Erdogan
im russischen getroffen und haben dort
über Berka Rabatt gesprochen also das
alles ist kein Zufall dass das jetzt
passiert
okay das ist ja vielleicht ein Konflikt
den man im ersten Moment auf eine sehr
kleine Region beschränkt sieht aber du
hast es jetzt gesagt da scheint ja
offenbar auch die große weltpolitische
Ebene eine Rolle zu spielen
genau das ist ja seit
man möchte fast sagen seit Menschen
gedenken also seit den 1920er Jahren als
es den Genozid der Türkei an den
Armenien gab seitdem ist dieser Konflikt
eigentlich schon da seitdem ist Russland
auf Seite Armeniens und die Türkei mit
Aserbaidschan verbündet dieser Konflikt
hat sich immer wieder hochgespielt und
abgekühlt es ist aber überhaupt keine
Lösung in Sicht gleichzeitig ist es
dadurch dass die Türkei auf einer Seite
steht Russland auf der anderen ein
Konflikt zwischen militärischen
Schwergewichten im Ukraine Krieg spielt
das natürlich jetzt alles an der
entscheidende Rolle man kann solche
Ereignisse gar nicht ohne den Ukraine
kriegt betrachten weil er die Türkei im
Ukraine kriegt immer wieder vermittelt
hat auch zu Russland Kontakte hält und
zur Ukraine das heißt Russland hatten
ganz klares Interesse geopolitisch mit
der Türkei im Kontakt zu bleiben im
Dialog zu bleiben und es deutet sich an
dass man dafür vielleicht sogar bereit
ist Armenien zu opfern
Armin ich würde gerne noch eine Frage an
dich weitergeben die uns bei Youtube
erreicht hat von Martin Marvin Reisen
inwiefern hat Putin denn Einfluss auf
Aserbaidschan
das ist ganz ganz schwer zu sagen es ist
wie gesagt klassisch so das Putin auf
Seite Armenien steht im Ukraine Krieg
ist aber Aserbaidschan für Putin immer
interessanter geworden in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten hat man dann eine
ganz klare Annäherung gesehen es hat
neulich der belarussische macht aber
Lukas schenko der ja ganz eng verbündet
mit Putin ist hat in aserbaidschanischen
Regierungschef und Diktator alias als
ein Mann von uns bezeichnet also es hat
sich ganz klar abgezeichnet das Russland
ein bisschen vielleicht den Kurs ändert
und in Richtung Aserbaidschan tendiert
weil das Land geopolitisch auch
wirtschaftlich auch militärisch für
Russland im Moment viel interessanter
ist als Familien
über die Rolle Russlands in diesem
Konflikt wollen wir im weiteren Verlauf
dieses Streams noch sprechen danke dir
Armin Körper für diese Informationen und
Einschätzungen aus Moskau danke dir ja
wir haben gerade von meinem Kollegen
Armin Körper gehört es geht bei diesem
Konflikt eben auch um die große
weltpolitische Bühne die Leidtragenden
sind aber natürlich vor allem die
Menschen vor Ort über die Lage in der
Region spreche ich gleich mit meiner
Kollegin Nina niedergeier im Studio
vorher hat uns Nina aber die aktuelle
Situation in Bergkarabach
zusammengefasst
Aufnahmen aus der Hauptstadt
bergkarabachs ein Wohngebäude offenbar
beschossen in Bergkarabach klingt es
nach Krieg Behörden vor Ort berichten
von Raketen und Artillerie Beschuss es
werden Verletzte und Tote gemeldet
das aserbaidschanische
Verteidigungsministerium veröffentlicht
diese drohnenaufnahmen
die Lage in der Karabach gilt seit
Monaten als katastrophal Schlange stehen
hoffen auf Brot für die gut 120.000
Menschen dort Realität die Regale sind
leer es fehlen Lebensmittel Medikamente
Benzin häufig fahren nicht mal mehr
Krankenwagen denn Aserbaidschan
blockiert die einzige Verbindungsstraße
zwischen Armenien und Bergkarabach
Hilfslieferungen kommen kaum noch durch
Armeniens Regierungschef paschingan
spricht von ethnischen Säuberungen er
bitte den UN-Sicherheitsrat und auch
Russland um Hilfe
Aserbaidschan erklärte man werde den
Militäreinsatz erst beenden wenn die
Führungen der Karabach zurücktritt
und bei mir im Studio ist jetzt meine
Kollegin Nina niagall hallo Nina schön
dass du da bist
wir haben es gerade schon in deinem
Beitrag kurz gesehen die Menschen vor
Ort sind seit neun Monaten von der
Versorgung abgeschnitten die Versorgung
über diesen Korridor was hast du für
Informationen wie geht's den Menschen
vor Ort aktuell
ja zunächst muss man sagen dass wir
leider selbst nicht vor Ort sein können
sondern wir sind abhängig von freien
JournalistInnen die noch vor Ort sind
von anderen Medien schaffenden die uns
Informationen Zulieferern aber wir haben
zum Glück die Möglichkeit immer wieder
auch mit einem Team zusammenzuarbeiten
die dann mit Menschen vor Ort sprechen
und die sagen schon seit Monaten die
Menschen sind hungrig die Apotheken sind
leer das Benzin fehlt wie gesagt auch
für Krankenwagen was jetzt natürlich
auch in der aktuellen Situation noch
umso prekärer ist weil eben zum Teil
verletzte nicht mal mit Krankenwagen
abgeholt werden können und damit zum
Beispiel im Beitrag diese Schlange
gesehen wo die Menschen für Brot
anstehen das war eine Schlange da ging
der die ziehen dann quasi Zettel mit
Nummern da gingen die Nummern bis 400
oder zum Teil über 400 und ab 300 ist
dann zum Schluss da gibt's dann kein
Brot mehr und also die die
Stimmen die uns davon vor Ort zu
geliefert wurden das zum Teil weinende
Frauen die gesagt habe ich kann schon
wieder irgendwie für meine Kinder kein
Abendessen mehr machen weil auch
irgendwann die Vorräte ausgehen und
gleichzeitig sind die Menschen aber so
war das zumindest die ganze Zeit vor
diesem Beschuss jetzt so dass sie sagen
wir wollen hier nicht weg weil das ist
unser unsere Heimat hier leben unsere
Familien und auch hier sind unsere
Angehörigen begraben weil es sich
natürlich hier auch um eine Region
handelt wir haben es gehört die häufig
bekämpft war und da sind natürlich die
Emotionen ja sehr sehr hoch auch was
sowas angeht wie schätzt du das denn ein
dass diese gewaltsame Eskalation an dem
was du gerade sagst sie wollen da nicht
weg glaubst du das verändert daran was
ja das ist jetzt die große Frage ehrlich
gesagt also es wird natürlich einmal
darauf ankommen wie kommen sie überhaupt
aus der Region raus weil tatsächlich nur
eine schmale Straße von Armenien nach
Bergkarabach führt in Bergkarabach leben
fast ausschließlich Arminia und
armenierinnen also zumindest in der
Region die noch nicht von Aserbaidschan
besetzt ist und ähm ob diese Leute jetzt
durch diesen Korridor der die ganze Zeit
von Aserbaidschan blockiert wird ob sie
da überhaupt raus können das ist die
eine Frage des andere ist das ob sie das
wollen also den wir haben zum Beispiel
einen jungen Mann immer wieder begleitet
also das Team vor Ort hat den immer
wieder getroffen und der hat z.B was ich
gerade sagte gesagt dass es unsere
Heimat mein Bruder ist in dem Krieg 2020
gestorben der liegt hier auf dem
Friedhof begraben die Aserbaidschaner
wollen uns aushungern und wir lassen uns
nicht aushungern vorher kämpfen wir das
ist das was wir zumindest bisher immer
gehört haben ob sie das jetzt so
durchziehen das müssen wir abwarten du
sagst die arbeitet vor Ort häufig mit
einem Team zusammen dass euch auch mit
Infos versorgt warum ist es denn so
schwierig von vor Ort zu berichten
also es kommt im Moment wie gesagt kaum
jemand rein oder raus also rein im
Prinzip gar nicht und das gilt natürlich
auch für internationale Journalisten
also es ist ich mir ist kein
internationaler Journalist oder
Journalistin bekannt der da reingekommen
ist auch wir haben schon mehrmals
versucht das ist jetzt durch die
Blockade eben vor allem dadurch
begründet dass niemand rein oder
rauskommt
oder fast niemand was aber auch schon
vorher so war ist dass dieses Gebiet
also bei Karabach liegt ja quasi
umschlossen von aserbaidschanischem
Territorium das heißt die
Aserbaidschaner entscheiden auch darüber
wer diese Straße passieren darf oder
auch nicht mit den Russen zusammen die
ja auch dort sogenannte Friedenstruppen
stationiert haben aber wenn die
Aserbaidschaner keine Erlaubnis erteilen
für Journalisten und Journalistinnen und
um da reinzukommen dann funktioniert es
eben leider auch nicht und das war sogar
auch schon vor der Blockade wir hatten
es letztes Jahr im November versucht
über Monate immer wieder nach einer
Kreditierung also nach einer
Arbeitserlaubnis vor Ort gefragt und die
wurde uns nicht erteilt
Armin Körper hat sie auch schon gesagt
Russland gilt oder galt zumindest lange
als Schutz macht Armeniens wie ist denn
das Verhältnis zwischen Russland und
Armenien aktuell also vor allem nicht
das politische Verhältnis so sehr
darüber sprechen wir gleich noch aber
das wie schauen die Menschen in Armenien
auf Russland und das Verhältnis die
Menschen fühlen sich alleine gelassen
also ich war november in Jere waren und
auch außerhalb von ihrer waren in der
Medien unterwegs es gibt immer wieder
Proteste gegen Russland gegen Putin als
ich in Armenien war kam Putin sogar zu
Besuch und es gab Proteste da sah man
dann Ukraine Flaggen da sah man
eu-flaggen USA Flaggen und das Absurde
ist ja ihr geht auf die politische
Situation noch ein aber eigentlich sind
Russland und Armenien im gemeinsamen
Verteidigungsbündnis auch mit Belarus
mit mehreren ehemaligen Sowjet
Republiken und die Armenia sagen halt
naja wenn uns Russland nicht mal hilft
wenn der Bach angegriffen wird oder wenn
unser eigenes Territorium angegriffen
wird und auch das ist schon passiert was
haben wir dann von dieser Partnerschaft
und haben wir nicht mehr davon wenn wir
uns Richtung Europa oder Richtung USA
entwickeln und das ist gerade was was
auch junge Menschen sich schon wünschen
und man muss natürlich auch sagen auch
in der Medien spielt das
selbstverständlich eine Rolle dass
Russland die Ukraine angegriffen hat und
das Leben dort natürlich viele auch ab
danke dir Nina Niebergall für deine
Eindrücke und Einschätzung und den
Besuch im Studio danke schön
ja den Konflikt wie gesagt zwischen
Armenien und Aserbaidschan den gibt es
schon lange warum und um was ist dabei
geht das hat meine Kollegin Lena
jentscha für euch zusammengefasst
der Ethno territoriale Konflikt zwischen
Armenien und Aserbaidschan um das Gebiet
Bergkarabach dauert bereits seit
Jahrzehnten an nach dem Zerfall der
Sowjetunion kommt es zwischen 1992 und
94 zum Krieg auf beiden Seiten gibt es
mehrere 10000 Todesopfer im September
2020 bricht der Krieg erneut aus
Aserbaidschan startete eine
Militäroffensive um das von mehrheitlich
Armenien bewohnte Gebiet zurück zur
erobern nach dem Sieg Aserbaidschans
wurde unter russischer Vermittlung am 9
November 2020 ein
Waffenstillstandsabkommen geschlossen
das Armenien zur Aufgabe großer Gebiete
Zwang seitdem sind in der Region
russische Truppen zufriedensicherung
stationiert
so wir wollen diesen Konflikt und den
Einfluss ausländischer Mächte vor allem
den von Russland und von Putin ihr seht
es jetzt hier gerade auch schon hinter
mir besser verstehen und dazu kann ich
jetzt sprechen mit Marcel rötig er ist
Leiter des Regionalbüros Süd Kaukasus
der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung in der
georgischen Hauptstadt Tiflis und mir
jetzt von dazu geschaltet hallo Ich
danke für Ihre Zeit
Russland galt ja lange als ich habe es
schon mehrfach gesagt als Schutz macht
Armeniens jetzt gab es ein
Friedensprozess unter der Federführung
Russlands warum hat der Waffenstillstand
trotzdem nicht gehalten
aber Russlands Wahrnehmung der Region
auch Russlands Prioritäten haben sich
geändert und das Resultat des ganzen
natürlichen Kombination der Russland
Schwächung sehen wir eben jetzt das also
bei John deutlich selbstbewusster
geworden ist als das in vergangenen
Zeiten gewesen ist das liegt auch daran
dass Armenien sich politisch verändert
hat es gab 2018 in demokratische
Revolution Ministerpräsident paschinen
Jahren selbst und ehemaliger Journalist
ist auf demokratischen Wege ins Amt
gekommen mit ihm auch seine ganze
Regierung ganz überwiegend sind dass
Leute die aus der Zivilgesellschaft
gekommen sind und die natürlich eher mit
Russland fremdeln und unbedingt Russland
auch mit mit ihnen
fremdet aber die Charakteristik des
Herrn alliiert fast eher zu der Putins
als die Persönlichkeit Pasching an tut
das mag sicherlich auch eine Rolle
spielen und so ist Russland vor allem
seit 2020 eher durch Untätigkeit auch
gefallen als durch eine Rolle die man
als Schutz macht verstehen würde
es gibt ein sehr bemerkenswertes Zitat
von Wladimir Putin dem Präsidenten
Russlands zu berkerabach und zwar hat er
auf den Tag genau heute vor einer Woche
folgendes gesagt da hören wir mal rein
Leute
das berkanabach zu Aserbaidschan gehört
worum geht es dann eigentlich das ist
die Schlüsselkomponente des ganzen
Problems der Status von Karabach wurde
von Armenien selbst festgelegt das ist
das ganze Problem
wie muss man Putin bei dieser Aussage
verstehen
ich glaube in dieser Äußerung erkennen
wir auch den russischen
Paradigmenwechsel es ist auch
sicherlich paschings Flexibilität
geschuldet das ist überhaupt dazu kommt
wahrscheinlich Jahren hat mittlerweile
selbst anders als seine amtsvorgänge
anerkannt dass aber nur Karabach
integraler Bestandteil Aserbaidschan ist
was er aber hinzufügt und auch gut die
nicht eingeht das ist in einer eben auch
armenierinnen und Armenien gibt die eben
auch autonomie-rechte dort genießen
sollen und dafür braucht man zehn Jahren
Unterstützung die kriegt er nicht in
Russland sondern faktisch hatte ich hier
mit Protein zu verstehen gegeben dass er
sich alias Forderungen zu beugen hat und
praktisch auch zugeben hat und das ist
ja das was wir nun auch ganz
offensichtlich erleben
wir haben da gerade schon mal kurz
darüber gesprochen ich würde sie das
trotzdem gerne noch mal fragen wie ist
denn das politische Verhältnis wir haben
jetzt gerade vor allem über die
Perspektive der Zivilbevölkerung
gesprochen aber wie ist das politische
Verhältnis zwischen Russland und
Armenien aktuell
es ist schlecht auch dazwischen
menschlichen Ebene das ganz offenkundig
und Paschen Jahren selber hat vor kurzem
wenn ein bemerkenswerten Interview
erklärt dass es ein Fehler war der
armenischen Politik sich auch Jahre
einseitig auf Russland zu verlassen und
man deswegen die Außenpolitik
diversifizieren müssen wenn wir heute
uns beispielsweise die Äußerung des
früheren Präsidenten mit Video anschauen
das ist natürlich Teil der russischen
Propaganda aber er hat klar gesagt dass
Patin Jan jetzt sinngemäß sehen muss wie
er damit zurechtkommt in der mit der
Lage in der sich da hinein manövriert
hat man fremdet miteinander und Armenien
hat es eben auch in den Taten umgesetzt
zum einen hat Armenien die Ratifizierung
des römischen Status begonnen also die
Mitgliedschaft Armeniens im
internationalen Strafgericht so dass
nichts anderes bedeuten müsste als dass
man Putin den Bündnispartner und den
Präsidenten der Schutz macht inhaftieren
und ausliefern müsste wenn er das
nächste Mal ihre Waren reist es geht
hierbei nicht um um Russland und Putin
es geht darum möglicherweise
japanische Kriegsverbrechen vor der
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof zu
bringen aber das nennt man eben in Kauf
zum anderen die Tatsache dass man
erstmals monetäre Hilfe für die Ukraine
leistet dass diese auch persönlich von
paschinians Frau überbracht worden ist
und dass man eine gemeinsame
Militärübung mit den USA abgehalten ist
meines Wissens nach sind die
amerikanischen Truppen auch noch immer
wenn auch in kleiner Zahl im Jere waren
vor Ort das ist geht um die Ausbildung
von Peacekeeper und wir alle wissen dass
Armenien keine nennenswerte Rolle als
Peacekeeper hat es gibt zwar Erfahrungen
aus dem Kosovo und dann Afghanistan dort
auch als Teil des deutschen Kontingents
aber das ist eben keine nennenswerte
Erfahrung sondern es ist eine deutliche
Symbolpolitik wie orientieren uns nach
Westen und man sucht eben auch den
Schulterschluss mit der EU vor allem mit
den Vereinigten Staaten ich glaube so
ein bisschen weil man in jedermann
erkannt hat dass man nichts mehr zu
verlieren hat und deswegen jetzt eben so
offen ist und man davon ausgehen muss
dass Russland sich jetzt in diesem
kriegerischen Auseinandersetzung die wir
in der Karabach erleben nicht einsetzen
wird auf armenischer Seite Armenien
wieder einmal alleine da steht und es
fraglich ist das politische überlebt
sie haben es gerade schon einmal gesagt
ich es gibt dazu noch eine Frage die uns
bei Youtube erreicht hat und zwar warum
haben die Amerikaner vor zwei Tagen das
amerikanische Militär ausgebildet auf
der Karabach ich glaube da fehlt ein
Verb aber die der Inhalt der Frage ist
klar
was können Sie dazu sagen
das amerikanische Militär nicht in
Bergkarabach ausgebildet ist es ja ist
ja nicht möglich dort überhaupt
hinzukommen der Karabach ist ist
aserbaidschanisches Territorium aber es
gab eben die Ausbildung von armenischen
Peacekeepern auch armenischen auf einem
armenischen Militärstützpunkt um eben ja
Armenien hierbei zu unterstützen ich
glaube dahinter ist eine gewisse
Symbolpolitik und auch ein Zeichen an
Aserbaidschan gewesen dass auch die
Vereinigten Staaten ganz genau gucken
was hier passiert ich glaube aber wenn
ich das davon mehr abzusehen ist weder
die USA noch irgendjemand anderes im
Westen wird sich militärisch auch die
Seite Armenien stellen diese Situation
und Patina hat ja auch selber bereits
angekündigt dass die armenischen
Streitkräfte weder in Kämpfe verwickelt
sind noch das noch das tun werden
sondern ganz im Gegenteil klare Orte
ausgegeben auch keinerlei Provokationen
zu reagieren nicht das aus diesen Krieg
möglicherweise noch ein Flächenbrand
wird der noch viel schlimmer ist der
Armenien hineinzieht und der
möglicherweise noch weitere an einer
starken hineinziehen könnte
eine weitere Frage die uns bei Youtube
erreicht hat lautet wie schlecht ist
denn das Ansehen Russlands dass es nicht
mehr in der Lage ist seine Rolle als
Schutz macht wahrzunehmen wer wird sich
da um orientieren bzw neue Bündnisse
suchen
das ist ganz offenkundig
Armenien und Russland waren immer sehr
sehr eng verbunden kulturell durch eine
große diastprogramm beispielsweise aber
auch wirtschaftlich armenien ist
Mitglied der eurasischen
Wirtschaftsunion
praktisch alle großen wichtigen
industriebe das Energiesystem des
bergbauwesen sind in russischer Hand
es gab enge zwischenmenschliche
Beziehung russisches eine Sprache die
man landläufig in Armenien spricht und
das ist auch überhaupt kein Problem
das bedeutet jetzt einen ziemlichen
Bruch und wir sehen uns heute Abend es
gibt Berichte von Protesten sowohl vor
dem Regierungssitz als auch vor der
russischen Botschaft in jede waren sowas
hat es niemals gegeben und ich glaube
was wir hier was wir hier erleben ist
ein Ausdruck sowohl der Schwäche
Russlands das ist eine direkte Folge von
Russland Einmarsch in die Ukraine dass
man anders wo eben nicht mehr in Lage in
der Lage ist die Ordnung auch recht zu
halten und sich deswegen auch um
orientieren muss ich sehe das russische
handeln auch als eine Folge an der
russischen Invasion in der Ukraine
zum anderen auch das möglicherweise die
Zeit der russischen Ordnungsmacht hier
im südkorso sich einen Ende zu neigt und
die Frage ist wenn Russland die ausfällt
wer diese Ordnung macht in der Zukunft
übernehmen wird
wenn die Karten hier gerade neu gemischt
werden
was glauben Sie denn wer könnte sich da
möglicherweise als neue Ordnungsmacht in
Stellung bringen
es ist sicherlich die Türkei auch wenn
die Türkei aufgrund der eigenen
wirtschaftlichen Lage sicherlich kein
Interesse hat auf einen auf einen Krieg
oder einem Krieg oder oder irgendwas in
in dieser Richtung aber Präsident
Erdogan das hatte auch heute vor der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen getan hat sich demonstrativ an
die Seite angestellt ist
aserbaidschanische Militär ist sehr sehr
eng mit dem türkischen Militär verbunden
faktisch ist das aserbaidschanische
Militär eine Armee auch NATO Standard
gut ausgebildet wurde und enge
Verpflichtungen mit der Türkei hat und
ähm ich sehe die Ambitionen der Türkei
sicherlich hier eine stärkere Rolle zu
spielen wenn dieser Krieg also momentan
sieht es ja danach aus dass es auch noch
Karbach beschränkt bleibt mit dem
Schlimmsten Fall einer ethischen
Säuberungen aber wenn das ganze noch auf
kernarmen also ob das armenische
Kernland übergehen sollte dann gucken
wir ganz schnell in den Süden Armeniens
in die Provinz Junik da ist es an der
engsten Stelle etwa 30 Kilometer in die
aserbaid chronische Enklave nach
hidjevan und diesen landkorridor fordert
alias hat er in den letzten Monaten
getan ein extrateritorialen Korridor
armenien ist bislang nur bereit eine
Straße einzurichten mit armenischen Zoll
und Passkontrollen aber eben keine extra
territoriale Versorgung
wiederum grenzt an die Türkei und das
heißt wenn es eine solche Landverbindung
gäbe dann hätte die Türkei freien Wege
bis ans Kaspische Meer das ruft
natürlich auch wieder in den Iran auf
den Zaun denn
Junik ist der die als südlichste Provinz
armenien hat eine direkte Landgrenze zum
Iran das ist die einzige Landverbindung
die der der Iran mit der eurasischen
Wirtschaftsunion hat das heißt wenn wir
auf die Nachbarn gucken dann dürfen wir
nicht nur auf Russland gucken dann
müssen wir vor allem auch die Türkei
gucken und auch den Iran
sie sagen sie sehen diese militärische
Auseinandersetzung dafür vor Ort jetzt
gerade auch als eine Folge des
russischen Einlass in der Ukraine
und ein Zeichen oder sozusagen eine
Konsequenz der russischen Schwäche
aktuell inwiefern könnte dieser Konflikt
und die jetzige militärische
Auseinandersetzung Putin denn auch
nutzen
ja wir haben ja eben erläutert dass
Putin und paschingan nicht sehr gut
miteinander können muss so auszudrücken
und paschinian steht mit dem Rücken zur
Wand es gibt wie wir gehört haben
Proteste in der Hauptstadt gegen
paschinian aber auch gegen Russland und
die Frage ist ob er das jetzt politisch
überlebt auch schon beim letzten Krieg
2020 sah es eng aus er hat danach
durchgezogene Neuwahlen noch mal eine
Mehrheit für sich geschafft aber wir
hatten zum Beispiel jetzt am Sonntag
Stadtratswahlen in jede waren etwa die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung gibt ja in ihre
Waren und es gab zum einen eine sehr
sehr niedrige Wahlbeteiligung zum
anderen hat paschings Partei die
Mehrheit verloren muss ich in
Koalitionspartner suchen also die Macht
basisbrücke und dann gucken wir auch die
armenische Opposition und die armenische
Opposition ist im größten Teil nichts
anderes als die früheren macht habe
Armeniens haben da reden wir vom
früheren Präsidenten Robert gottschalen
der persönlich sehr enge Beziehung zu
Putin hat selbst auch aus einer gonika
kommt und das was glaube ich zu
befürchten steht ist sollte paschingan
jetzt hier gestürzt werden dass diese
alten Eliten zurückkommen die mehr nach
moskaustreife tanzen und dann auch
möglicherweise Armenien sich wieder
politisch mehr nach Moskau umorientiert
das heißt Moskau müsste militärisch gar
nichts machen ich male jetzt mal ein
Szenario was gelegentlich in ihre Waren
kursiert quasi als der Worst Case es
gäbe ein offenen Krieg zwischen Armenien
und Aserbaidschan den Armenien verlieren
würde es gäbe erneute Unruhen oder
schlimmere Unruhen in ihre Waren wurde
zurücktreten und die früheren Machthaber
kämen wieder zurück an die Macht dann
wäre auch das kurze Zwischenspiel der
armenischen Demokratie ist seit 2018
begann auch zu Ende und die neuen
machthabe würden dann ihr Heil suchen
mit Russland weil man eben traditionell
sagt Russland ist die einzige Schutz
macht die wir hier hatten weil niemand
anderes vor einem der besten sich
jeweils nennenswert für Armenien
einsetzen wird und dann im schlimmsten
Fall Armenien beispielsweise in den
unionsdaten Russland und Belarus führen
würde
man kann ja auch so argumentieren
Belarus hat jetzt den Zugriff auf
taktische Atomwaffen aus Russland das
ist ja der ultimative Garant für die
staatliche Souveränität und das würde
sicherlich Parteien der Bevölkerung in
Armenien im schlimmsten Fall auch auch
verhaften und so hätte Russland in dem
ganzen auch noch etwas gewonnen auch
wenn man sinngemäß mit der Türkei teilen
müsste wenn Aserbaidschan gestärkt ist
aber man würde eben dafür sorgen dass
diese Demokratie in Armenien nicht nach
Westen abdriftet sondern sich noch mehr
Russland bindet
ik wir bekommen natürlich während wir
uns hier unterhalten natürlich die ganze
Zeit Fragen und Kommentare zum Thema und
zwar diskutieren bei uns im Chat viele
oder kritisieren viele das Armeen das
Armenia das Gebiet von Aserbaidschan ja
quasi besetzt hätten die Armenia aber
Minion aber als Opfer dargestellt wird
in dieser Auseinandersetzung wie ist das
einzuordnen
praktisch gehört
Bergkarabach oder die nicht anerkannte
Republik arzach zu Aserbaidschan das ist
vollkommen richtig und in den 90er
Jahren hat Armenien den ersten Krieg
auch gewonnen und hat auch
aserbaidschanisches Gebiet damals
besetzt was soviel Zeiten nicht zum
historischen Berg Karabach gehört hat
das heißt es war lange genug
aserbaidschanisches Gebiet besetzt es
gab Vertreibungen es gab beiden Seiten
erheblich auch
zivile Verluste großes Leid auf beiden
Seiten aber eben auch Hass und
Revanchismus der damals entstanden ist
und lange Zeit lief es eben bei diesem
Status Quo diesen Status Quo hat ja auch
Russland gesichert durch die 90er Jahre
durch die Zweitausender bis irgendwann
alliiert diesen Status Quo mit Gewalt
geändert hat und er hat den Beweis
herbei geführt dass es möglich ist ein
Status Quo einmal mit Gewalt auf
revanchistischer Art und Weise zu
verändern zu seinen Gunsten
2020 hat der Westen größtenteils
geschwiegen wir haben diesen Konflikt
nicht nicht mit der Entschlossenheit
begegnet wie wir beispielsweise im Fall
der Ukraine gehandelt haben auch weil
wir mit Blick auf die Krim natürlich
auch das Prinzip der territorialen
Integrität geachtet haben und klar ist
Karbach gehört nun mal eben zu
Aserbaidschan die Frage ist aber auch
was macht man mit den armenierinnen und
Armenien die dort leben Armenien selbst
sagt sind etwa 120.000 ich gehe eher von
60 bis 70 000 aus die noch da sind auch
die haben Rechte und auch die haben
einen ein Recht auf Leben und ein Recht
auf Unversehrtheit und auch
Selbstbestimmung und das ist genau der
Kern dieses Konfliktes und was ist
nämlich geht die Frage a territorial
Integrität versus B und
Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Menschen die
dort leben
Erotik bundesaußenministerin hat sich
heute in New York auch dazu geäußert und
zwar hat sie gesagt den Beschuss sofort
einstellen und an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückkehren welchen Einfluss hat
Deutschland bzw hat Europa denn
überhaupt in der Region
muss positiv zu sagen Europa hat seit
2020 sich wesentlich mehr eingesetzt als
man das jemals zuvor gemacht hat wir
haben seit diesem Jahr eine EU
Beobachtermission auf der armenischen
Seite der Grenze nicht in Bergkarabach
auch nicht am latschenkorridor aber eben
auch da wenigstens der Grenze die ist
halt ein sehr hohe Anerkennung in
Armenien es gibt immer mal die Hoffnung
dass diese Mission beispielsweise auch
auf aserbaidschanischen Territorium
arbeiten müsste eben auch dass man auch
beiden Seiten sichtbar ist auf beiden
Seiten auch vielleicht mal sowas wie ein
rotes Telefon oder ähnliches hat dann
eben
bestimmte Eskalation vermeiden kann
bevor sie passieren das ist momentan
noch nicht möglich aber auch Charles
Michael ist hier besonders aktiv Rahmen
der Gespräche eigentlich sprechen gerade
alles sprechen die Russen es sprechen
die Amerikaner sprechen die Europäer zum
Ergebnis ist man noch nicht so richtig
bekommen wie man sehen es gibt eher die
Eskalation zum anderen hat natürlich
Europa ein großes liberich wenn es um
Aserbaidschan geht und das ist die
Erdgas Frage also bei Johannes
rohstoffreich ist ein Rohstoff Partner
für die Europäische Union hat in dem
Sinne natürlich auch was unsere
wirtschaftlichen Interessen angeht mehr
zu bieten als es Armenien bieten kann
aber es ist natürlich auch etwas wo
Europa mit Aserbaidschan empfindlich
treffen könnte wenn wir hier
beispielsweise um Energie Sanktion reden
würden und das ist etwas was nicht immer
Interesse sein kann
ich würde Ihnen gerne noch abschließend
eine Frage mitgeben die wir bei Youtube
bekommen haben und zwar ist die Angst
vor ethnischen Säuberungen durch
Aserbaidschan denn berechtigt und daran
von mir angeschlossen die Frage wie
sehen Sie denn welchen weiteren Verlauf
sehen Sie für diesen Konflikt
ich möchte die Angst ist berechtigt aus
dem einfachen Grund wir sprachen eben
davon dass es ein ein uralter Konflikt
ist und der Hass hat sich über
Generationen angestaut das heißt der
Hass auf beiden Seiten und ein
Zusammenleben ein friedliches
Zusammenleben ist kann ich mir bei
weitem so schnell nicht vorstellen
zum einen das zum anderen wenn
Aserbaidschan nun anbietet sogenannte
humanitäre Korridore also eine Eröffnung
des Latschen dass die Zivilisten
ausreisen können gibt es auch der
armenischen Seite wo Skepsis in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten gab es immer
wieder Festnahmen man muss sich
vorstellen von den Menschen die dort
leben praktisch die komplette männliche
Bevölkerung über 18 hat mal
Militärdienst in dem quasi
streitkräftenbach geleistet und wir
haben mehrere Kriege gehabt und so gab
es eben auch Fälle dass Männer
festgenommen worden sind bei dem Versuch
über den Latschen
weil man ihm Kriegsverbrechen ja
vorgeworfen hat das natürlich alles
Dinge die wir im individual fallen nicht
100% nachvollziehen können
und gerade für die männliche Bevölkerung
ist das etwas was man sich was was man
sich schwer vorstellen kann dass die
einfach so ohne weiteres ausreisen
können ich meine Meinung nach geht es
nur unter internationale Aufsicht
das ist das ist diese Möglichkeit ja
gibt es die Zivilbevölkerung dort dort
in Sicherheit ist ansonsten fürchte ich
das Schlimmste nämlich die Vertreibung
dann ist die caravanfrage ein für alle
mal gelöst aber es wird eben dazu dass
die verbliebenen Armenien und Armenien
ja
werden würden wie es weitergeht für den
Moment sieht das alles eben danach aus
militärisch die letzten Stunden weisen
darauf hin dass Aserbaidschan alles das
einsetzt was man im Arsenal hat also
einschließlich auch der Luftwaffe und
Bodentruppen
da sieht es zurzeit nicht nach einer
Entspannung aus die Führung da waren
noch karabachs hat Angeboten zu
verhandeln also bei Jan sagt
Verhandlungen nur wenn die
illegalen militärischen Formationen
sich auflösen also sprich wenn man
kapituliert das bleibt also hier bei der
Maximalforderung
der schlimmste Fall wie gesagt ein
Flächenbrand das wäre dann wenn sich in
ihre waren die politische Führung
entscheiden würde den Karabach Armenien
und Armenien zu Hilfe zu allen
militärisch das ist gar nicht so einfach
denn wie gesagt es gibt keine
Landverbindung und Legend Korridor
stehen etwa 2000 Russen
und dann ist das Gelände Berge und das
kann ich mir militärisch nicht
vorstellen zumal die armenischen
Streitkräfte a sowieso auf dem
technischen Standard der Sowjetunion der
70er und 80er Jahre sind eh noch immer
von der letzten kriegst Niederlage 2020
noch immer die Wunden lecken und das ist
auch ein offenes Geheimnis in ihre Waren
man hat bei den großen Waffen bestellt
in den letzten zweiten und Jahren die
man nicht bekommen hat das heißt die
Arme die Streitkräfte haben sich auch
nicht nennenswert erholt sind eigentlich
faktisch nicht in der Lage da in
irgendein Abenteuer zu gehen zumal wie
gesagt das ein Angriff auf Aserbaidschan
wäre und das hätte eine Gegenreaktion
zur Folge wir sehen bei den
aserbaidschanischen
Truppenkonzentrationen dass diese auch
entlang der regulären armenisch
aserbaidschanischen Grenze stehen wie
gesagt dann gucken wir wieder auf den
Süden dann gucken wir wieder auf Iran in
roten Linien des Iran und hier glaube
ich macht man sich in Barcode schon
Gedanken ob man ob es das wert ist
vielleicht ein letzter Gedanke es gab
eine militärische Eskalation im
September letzten Jahres mit etwa 400
Toten damals hatte Aserbaidschan
militärisch gesehen günstige Höhen auch
im Süden Armeniens eingenommen aber wie
wir aus Barcode gehört haben auch bei
den Menschen eine allgemeine Stimmung
von war es das wert und muss das jetzt
schon wieder sein und ich sehe eine
gewisse Kriegsmüdigkeit in jedem Fall in
Armenien und ich sehe auch eine
Kriegsmüdigkeit oder keine allzu große
Begeisterungen Aserbaidschan für einen
langanhaltenden und schlimmen Krieg weil
eben die Länder das auch genug
mitgemacht haben und deswegen hoffe ich
letztlich auch die Vernunft sowohl in
Aserbaidschan als auch in Armenien in
Armenien sich jetzt nicht zu provozieren
zu lassen und ein schlimmeres Abenteuer
einzutreten und den barcoo ist bei dem
sein zu lassen und von Westen einen
voran von Europa jetzt alles dafür daran
zu setzen dass die Lage wieder unter
Kontrolle gerät
Marcel Röthig Leiter des Regionalbüros
Südkaukasus der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung
in Tiflis vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
für die Einschätzung heute Abend
ja soweit unser ZDF heute live zu der
gewaltsamen Eskalation in Bergkarabach
wenn ihr da auf dem Laufenden bleiben
wollt dann schaut am besten vorbei in
unserer ZDF heute App soweit von uns
danke fürs zuschauen tschüss